in this video we're going to talk a
little bit about order of operations and
i want you to pay close attention
because really everything else that
you're going to do in mathematics is
going to be based on you having a solid
grounding in order of operations so what
do we even talk mean when we say order
of operations so let me give you an
example the whole point is so that we
have one way to interpret a mathematical
statement so let's say i have the
mathematical statement 7
7 plus
3 times 5.
now if we didn't all agree on on order
of operations there would be two ways of
interpreting this statement you could
just read it left to right so you could
say well let me just take seven plus
three you could say seven plus three and
then multiply that times five and seven
plus three is ten
and then you multiply that by five
ten times five it would get you
50. so that's one way you would
interpret it if we didn't agree on an
order of operations maybe it's a natural
way you just go left to right another
way you can interpret it you say oh i
like to do multiplication before i do
addition so you might interpret it as
i'll try to color code it 7 plus and you
do the 3 times 5 first
7 plus 3 times 5
which would be
7 plus 3 times 5 is
and 7 plus 15 is 22
is 22. so notice we interpreted the
statement in two different ways this was
just straight left to right doing the
addition then the multiplication this
way we did the multiplication first then
the addition we got two different
answers and that's just not cool in
mathematics if so this was part of
some effort to send something to the
moon because two people interpreted a
different way or not one computer
interpreted one way and another computer
interpreted another way that the
satellite might go to mars so this is
just completely unacceptable and that's
why we have to have an agreed upon order
of operations an agreed upon way to
interpret this statement
so the agreed upon order of operations
is to do parentheses first let me write
it over here parentheses
parentheses
first then do exponents if you don't
know what exponents are don't worry
about it right now
exponents and in this video we're not
going to have any exponents in our
examples so you don't really have to
worry about for this video then you do
multiplication i'll just write
mult short for multiplication then you
do multiplication and division next they
kind of have the same level of priority
and then finally you do addition and
subtraction
finally you do addition and subtraction
so what is this order of operations let
me label it this right here that is the
agreed upon order
of
operations and if we follow these order
of operations we should always get to
the same answer for a given statement so
what does this tell us what is the best
way to interpret this up here well we
have no parentheses parentheses look
like that those little curly things
around numbers we don't have any
parentheses here i'll do some examples
that do have parentheses we don't have
any exponents here but we do have some
multiplication and division or we
actually just have some multiplication
so with the order of operations say do
the multiplication and division first so
it says do the multiplication first
that's a multiplication so it says do
this operation first it gets priority
over addition or subtraction so if we do
this first we get the 3 times 5 which is
15 and then we add the 7. the addition
or subtraction i'll do it here addition
we just have addition
just like that so we do the
multiplication first get 15 then add the
7 22. so based upon the agreed order of
operations
this right here is the correct
answer the correct way to interpret this
statement let's do another example i
think it'll make things a little bit
more clear
and i'll do the example in pink
so let's say i have
plus 3
7 plus 3
put some parentheses there
times
divided by
minus
times
6. so there's all sorts of crazy things
here but if you just follow the order of
operations you'll simplify it in a very
i guess clean way and hopefully we'll
all get the same answer so let's just
follow the order of operations the first
things we have to do is look for
parentheses are there parentheses here
yes there are there's parentheses around
the seven plus three so it says let's do
that first so seven plus three is ten so
this we can simplify just looking at
this order of operations 210
times all of that let me copy and paste
that so i don't have to keep rewriting
it
so let me copy and let me paste it
so that simplifies to 10 times all of
that we did our parentheses first
then what do we do there are no more
parentheses in this expression then we
should do exponents i don't see any
exponents here and just so if you're
curious what exponents look like an
exponent would look like you know 7
squared you'd see these little small
numbers up in the top right we don't
have any exponents here so we don't have
to worry about it then it says to do
multiplication and division
next so where do we see multiplication
of we have a multiplication a division a
multiplication again
now
when you have multiple operations at the
same level when our order of operations
multiplication and division are at the
same level then you do left to right
so in this situation you're going to
multiply
by 4
and then divide by 2. you won't multiply
by 4 divided by 2. and but then we'll do
the 5 times 6 before we do the
subtraction right here so let's let's
figure out what this is so we'll do this
multiplication first
we'll do that multiplication first we
could simultaneously do this
multiplication because it's not going to
change things but i'll do things one
step at a time
so the next step we're going to do is
this 10 times 4 10 times 4 is 40.
10 times 4 is 40. then you have 40
divided by 2.
let me
copy and paste all of that again then it
simplifies to that right there remember
multiplication division they're at the
exact same level so we're going to do it
left to right you could also express
this as multiplying by one half and then
it wouldn't matter the order but for
simplicity multiplication and division
go left to right
so then you have 40 divided by 2 minus 5
times 6.
so division you just have one division
here you want to do that
this is going to take you have this
division then you have this
multiplication they're not together so
you can actually kind of do them
simultaneously and to make it clear that
you do this before you do the
subtraction because multiplication
division take priority over addition
subtraction we could put parentheses
around them to say look we're going to
do that and that
first before i do that subtraction
because multiplication division have
priority
so 40 divided by 2 is 20 we're going to
have that minus sign
minus 5 times 6 is
30. 20 minus 30 is equal to
negative 10 and that is the correct
interpretation of that so i want to make
something very very very clear if you
have things at the the same level so if
you have
1 plus 2 minus 3
plus 4
minus 1. so addition and subtraction are
all at the same level in order of
operations you should go left to right
so this you should interpret this as one
plus two is three
three so this is the same thing as three
minus three plus four minus one then you
do three minus three is zero
plus four minus one or this is the same
thing as four minus one which is the
same thing as three just go left to
right
same thing if you have
multiplication and division all on this
they're the same level so if you have
four
times two divided by
times 2 you do 4 times 2 is 8 divided by
3 times 2 and you say 8 divided by 3 is
well we'll get a fraction there it would
be eight thirds so this would be eight
thirds
times two and then eight thirds times
two is equal to
sixteen
over three that's how you interpret it
you don't do this multiplication first
and then take the divide the 2 by that
and all of that now the one time where
you can be loosey-goosey with order of
operations if you have all addition or
all multiplication so if you have 1 plus
5 plus 7 plus 3 plus 2
does not matter what order you do it in
you can do the 2 plus 3 you could go
from the right to the left you could go
from the left to the right you could
start someplace in between if it's only
all addition and the same thing is true
if you have all multiplication if it's 1
times five times seven times three times
two does not
matter what order you're doing there
that's only wet it's all multiplication
or
all addition if there's some division in
here if there's some subtraction here
you're best off just going left to right